[Music]
so uh what I want to do today just like
yesterday we went from here to here
right okay and it shouldn't be
different and part of the difference is
that you're still thinking with your
egoic instead of feeling what's going on
you when you when you feel what's going
on it's just forces you feel it's just
forces that's all I'm feeling okay so
we're going to
uh we were working on this okay boom and
now he's going to hold one hand and hold
the stick it's just a stick don't think
of it as a knife okay and you're going
to work the same forces
you don't have to worry about uh
switching or anything like
that okay got it okay try it
it grab any way it doesn't
[Music]
matter
for for
so don't just use the knife side as
again switch switch
[Music]
it is club and he'll grab near the hand
that's so it's going to be exactly like
the knife right it's exactly like the
knife all right
okay near near somewhere around here
okay TR okay hold hold near like you're
holding a knife and there you go no grab
knife
life work with the energy
near the hand
okay and now he'll come up up near the
end okay up near the end
okay try
I'm try to Leverage The the little stick
use the use the for
do you guys understand what I
mean you don't we don't work in Lage I
know it looks like we do but we don't we
don't work in
leverage so he's driv I'm not going to
try to I don't do that kind of stuff
right I don't do that kind of stuff
wherever he's holding I feel that
pressure that you want to try to get
leverage on and instead I use that so
here here you
see this is this is better cuz that to
go even
lower you see everything should have got
easier not
harder because I I have big arms now to
do all this kind of
stuff deeper penetration you understand
that
okay so I can't I can never so I can
never get this thing to go all the way
around with my little arm but now I can
you see with this movement here like
don't try to don't try to take it
there you can now go
way you see and I could never do that
everything should be getting easier not
harder okay
yes yes
yes follow the same rules foot
claw spirals
so that one's kindy of get you cop each
three of you so what happen is you grab
okay and your here and uh you're trying
to get that what you did is you just
relied on this
one so when he's there yes the young
hand will make that lighter you see but
I still take the angle that's going to
in and of itself
do the technique you see that so don't
don't get stuck here and then leave that
there the two hands
together are doing that you see and if
you some of you had different
grip yep okay it's even
easier on this one okay so instead of
you're like here you see that and then
what you did is this but you use the the
two hands
are doing it okay see how I spill over
spill over and push
okay I want you to use both hands I
don't want them holding the Joe and then
you just use the young hand right all
that one got that one got
caught for
see using both
hands that more down need more
down there you
go so that one you you got to do
something different if you want that if
you want that little
if you're if you're going to take that
one then you can't do that one this way
it's fighting that you get
it this one has to be
tighter see that
okay if you do it don't pick anything
you should just feel what's happening
so what happened on that one if you did
want her to do the
roll why didn't
she uh my angle with the stick hand
stick hand was then I don't know it's
too too high the other hand hi okay so
same thing like you want their hip to go
over then the head head has to lower so
on this one her front hip was too high
if you lower the that arm maybe you
lower that more and then that'll be
enough to get the hip over
okay take your stick is kind of
wavering as he grabs your stick is doing
you get that like why would it do that
if he grabs and then I connect to him
you you get what I'm saying like why why
is it why should my stick have any kind
of wavering at all you see that you
shouldn't I'm I'm trying to get leverage
on that and that's Happ it does doesn't
I don't use the L I don't use the just
the
energy en every
time my stick doesn't have to go until I
find
it okay so stop cuz then you're going to
need wrist strength and grip strength
and all that kind of okay go again
m
feel the
energy not not him don't feel his grip
feel inertia momentum
gravity good
R take that
that take this
it's
let's do one more with
short it's all Obion but let's keep our
okay he he'll use two hands now on the
on the
joke not he's not grabbing my other hand
does that make sense okay and then I do
the same thing
[Music]
feel where he's taking
him okay got it you climb all over the
Joe whatever you
want for
[Music]
no
leverage Lage
don't take
T you want to hold it with your hands
hold two want hold one hand start with
two with one doesn't matter it's
energy for
leage
all right so you got get a little
more you can combine do you
understand you can start with two hands
and you're going be here I can change
hands you see I change hands okay and
then I just do my tilt and I this
going down on the got it does that make
sense I turn I can
in you got to think outside you're over
here and you're like must get
leverage when you're trying not to he
pushes right look where he's taking it
you see come around here there I
go oh you look here that make sense
okay good yes let's play with that Force
the energy
so you felt if I pull this down I'm
going to just be pulling against her
right so he th it left it there took the
other opening with the body Ard part
okay you can't pick things I can't think
you just feel
you start judging you're like oh it's
wrong it's not
WR don't get l
so uh let me exaggerate a
point see
okay just no there's no reason why I
have to
okay we we're our goal is not to do
techniques our goal is to play with the
force and the for if I'm playing with
the force correctly it's effortless okay
try it again
good nice nice lots of lots of
adaptation there
okay it's again didn't pull down all I
need you to tell then I'm going to take
your face out and then the Joe's going
to get really light
again
good good
and then at the end that Joe is going to
get light so that's when you use it
okay
leverage Leverage
your
face
what all right uh any questions or
comments so now I actually have more
leverage you see I have more Lage to do
things with more
Lage more Lage
more things should not get harder for me
things things get easier for
me do you understand and you can do the
same thing just let
go all your all your stuff comes into
play all of it comes into play
okay and everything should get easier
just
don't no right no don't do that keep it
going around
face fir
easier okay it
be careful CU Force goes up
so don't kill it don't kill each
other
good stay in the force not not that
technique selection
so you know again like your IO purist
are going to go ah you gave it your
weapon you know after I crack this skull
on the street I'll pick it back up do
you get it okay that was my point on
that last throw like it's better to do
that than you fight for the weapon you
get in a leverage fight you might you
might lose it anyways might as well take
the kill blow which is the head to the
back of the Street then get your weapon
okay and again remember the for is going
to get Amplified
okay if if we're doing it right it gets
easier if we're doing it wrong it gets
harder because I'm further away from
the got it I'm too close to the it's all
in my GP
actually you can always climb up to Joe
you understand just and the last one I
let go I did two hands I did no hands I
switched hands you can climb up the Joe
if you want to
good he climbed up there you see
fun
for for
[Music]
you see
that
go thank you you me in
in the Jo and then the Joe takes in
there as opposed to you're over here and
I hope you can throw that down and I
hope he doesn't let go versus like
that you got it you guys understand so
same thing when you're doing like this
[Music]
one
in turn
Bas
Boom the you guys
understand start looking on that as
supposed to like you're here and no here
boom that way okay got it bring bring
your body art more into it don't don't
do
iido and then be careful I'm barely
touching R
okay
face then the J
and then the joke
then the Joe the Joe does
throw that's
it Jo does
throw feel the energy not so you're
going to feel that the Joe can still
move the initial energy that's why you
do it even though you've launched him
yeah you're not doing it cuz you got I
threw him but let's throw him all the
way you see okay
go for
B you're trying to find that last one
that you did I actually I thought that
was
nice know what you did I don't know how
you would know what you did was cool
transferred up to the to the arm I don't
know how you did it but it was
cool don't go searching okay let let
those s happened all right I don't know
what I did all
right so let let his spiral displacement
move the J you you understand when
he that's what I'm doing I'm not going
like this so my hand doesn't he he I'm
here he goes to grab right good all
right that if if you're doing that
strategy
okay where's my t-shirt or
not get the
base then the
joke oh you could you could have CED the
traia did you see it you don't have to
throw dead is dead do you you understand
we had the TR question you know what I'm
talking
about
so somehow you got to get over it here
and you're right here here it is right
here you see that's when you should have
gone but you're like oh no
okay and then
the when his base is gone like what
what's going on is you feel there is an
obstacle and I don't have leverage so
I'm telling you don't seek it but I'm
not saying don't use it so once you take
the base now you have his body falling
in the direction that your Joe goes now
it's not contesting so after you take
the base go back to the weapon okay and
add to the force
okay although you turn your waist and we
don't turn our
waist come on one more time
and like I told you already there's a
lot more Force just keep contact don't
don't start sending her
over use it but I don't want you to SL
each
there was again I got
that I don't know I can't see it but
it's cool
face Crush Crush right there
hey good good on you use the joke but
you're still picking techniques
okay all right so now if he has the joke
and he skis at me got it and then it's
the same thing you see you're just
working those
forces do you understand why should it
change I had to J look right here who's
steeve I don't now okay so might as well
him here you goes and base
jump
okay face job always
base there is there any beginners here
tonight no okay so we going to do the
base forces not people
evva feel the
energy
fores
for for
my point in saying when you like who ski
is get here you understand okay so to do
that you go to ski and you just you have
to get out of the
way there's y when he draws so he
already moving so that Hees comes out
you get it you're you're not here and
then he skes that's not when you go he
see you move it and you're in you catch
it and then then however you catch it
you feel the forces this is too heavy
you see it's too heavy so it's too heavy
because he's probably going that way so
I could do that what do I got to do with
my base my base goes in here first so I
move this to create the the angle and I
come in boom and
right so same thing on the Y enter catch
it move it boom
Bas kind of like in that order oh look
boom catch
boom just get there boom here I'm
there you guys got it
you
can you can AI does it matter you okay
aumi on this side does it matter
Bas of
course don't stop
him so I as I get in there I get the
motion and keep everything going
boom and just playing with those
forces
[Music]
works
okay
go for
[Music]
let me give you
another okay so
uh when he throws his strikes I touch
you see I touch to to adhere do you get
it you have to do it says in
here oh when he SK I'm not going like
that
he SE and I'm here and I got the
adhesion pay attention not the grips
touch wherever I touch and then then I
can find my grips you see on that one I
was here right and then I can find my
grips
okay you're going to grip Miss and then
you're like what all
right if you get the grip you give the
grip if you don't get the grip you get
the ad
Yes Energy yes
[Applause]
yes don't think try it
again don't think feel don't pick it
me okay
inter when they draw the Joe
back two more
be connected already
connected
[Music]
go so let's do do that again and let's
find the Joe cuz I think it's there so
you let it go by and you went to the
spine cool start looking for the J yes
got
it and I think you can find it before
that
okay good
okay don't pick
technique don't get
bored the
get the base you don't have to kill the
base but at least get in there
don't pick don't
pick we can't stop
them let me give you one
okay so uh I think it's on the you're
fine I'll fix it it came around this
place okay got it then a
circle turn and this right here you see
but you got to hit that you got to hit
that leg
okay so if he's skiing here onto this
side turn turn there's the leg
enter just feel that the
energy effort L boom
bo okay I I want you to feel
the the transference you're going to
enter to his uh outside what what foot
were you Ste with r left
okay good
what seamless it's abrupt transf for his
energy if you're you're you're you're
sof come around keep him going keep him
going
[Music]
around keep them going keep them going
that's what I'm doing got it you're like
picking up you're finding that leverage
it's heavy here you see so I go around
the hand gets TI right there's nothing
on here
okay face
okay and it's not much base it's it's on
the lower part
okay feel the
flow yes then I after I clear the leg
then the Joe does come in all right just
don't kill
anyone but I want you to feel it I don't
want you to to let that energy go and go
away
you got to be on the inside all right
your inside hand stays on the inside all
right right hand turn PM up grab it
there it is leg
back more towards
you
yes throw the
come back let's start over remember
again here trap you're trapping the Joe
is what you're
doing so what I mean by trapping is you
make open-ended
triangles do you get it and then the the
then the thing is there so I'm moving
like that and then I catch it you see
then I'll have
it is it is the same thing with the
punches that's what I do got to touch
his Center but I'm not ever going to
catch like this so I'm here like that
you see and then quack I can get the the
arm bar there in that in that little
trap that's there you get it so same
thing
here don't go for the Joe go for the
deviation and you feel the energy okay
cuz we got to keep him moving cannot
stop
him
yes Bas your back foot look
ground yeah if I was Dred his coming off
face you
see all right any
questions you can see though right it's
the same it's not two hearts doesn't
matter where you touch me whether it's
my wrist or my shoulders that's
yesterday's and it doesn't matter if you
touch me at all if you're touching
something I'm holding and it doesn't
matter if I'm holding it or you were
holding it that doesn't matter it
doesn't change anything but you should
also recognize your freaking mind
changed everything like it took a little
while to get to the next one and realize
it's exactly the same do you get that so
you got to wash that because that's the
propensity of the ego Tri protype mind
to compartmentalize and make distinct
but it's not truth it's toally falsehood
okay so that the reason why I don't know
what I'm doing because every single
thing feels exactly the same it
just feels exactly the same that hence
there's not two Arts I'm never doing two
things that means I'm not doing three
things I'm not doing four things I'm not
doing 50 things okay so it doesn't
matter this is why we don't do that
whole I lexicon of
techniques because there's only one
technique
what's the point okay why we don't spend
so much time on Jo do like we are doing
Jo do do you get it okay